okay back it's a barcycle baba were
playing this game called I love my
things I think it's just a damn outside
you know don't get so crazy now Walsh
introduction yes Saint blotting I'm
enjoying for so long that I couldn't
remember right where the [ __ ] I was
going like the roads all look the same
the shadows out there never really got
any closer that's annoying
it seemed like the night will never end
if I just kept on calm you know it's
reasonable but all I wanted was a place
to sleep but it but how it works and
save you ain't seen a gas station on
Sosa I was about the pass out the wheel
and something began to take shape ahead
a building I couldn't believe my luck it
look like a hotel okay let's begin this
let me enjoy those really necessary okay
man this is my car
skaters start oh wow it's always a
little weird and you go back okay okay
shut the gate got that camera in alright
alright oh wow this is a beautiful place
any flashlights in here at freaking dark
in here hello hello hello son here Oh
what oh my god huh welcome oh my god are
they not supposed to be like dolls
there's a factual innovation for the
person oh you poor thing you look like
you're ready to drop you want to run
well I already did the box for tonight
but suppose there's any place else free
to go out here though oh yeah shaky
moving go ahead up to room 12 we could
set up in the morning okay okay it's
over the doors
yeah that suppose is supposed to your
room fold or just put the key in there
okay oh my and I use this okay locked
you guys not room 12 that room tough
wait can I go up here or something yeah
okay
is this room what room is this
12 uh-huh maybe this has worked out I
don't I don't understand a wire that the
numbers are
I can't marry that's it they can't eight
what's an eight okay
at 12 when I really lock down like two
places okay not too bad the bathroom why
is it like a hallway
wait Chuck freaking dark in here then I
want lights are is no life in this game
sleep Oh bunny locate oh wow there are
some 1a all right what it gave me sir
what sir the bar is open grace of want
some company and your car is gone now
okay
nothing made me back anything in the
bathroom man it's freakin dark or we
search don't forget legs in this wait
it's a control zone a flashlight it's
why I keep pressing F okay like I said
he'd get a flashlight cuz why doesn't do
anything okay oh no is that hottie with
a body down there and st. say hello
beatiful oh my god the guy's disgusting
and it looks like something is troubling
new cars dawn why I guess that makes us
strength it huh huh
keep me near up for you Joe by the way
yeah got a lot of my mind myself I'm
waiting on a special lady you know grace
the locker room great just strange
things but she's not well maybe it turns
to the manager back a car though yes
wash yeah where'd you go ah what the
hell
I forget duck nice up can I get here
does anybody go out here I'm not
freaking out here
okay where's the manager is it over here
open yes is the bar all right what is
that
I need a freaking flashlight I spent
lady's not here she's in the corner
table that she looks beautiful in the
lamplight what the hell is that nothing
to light it with okay she's not here yet
it meets pretty good though okay I'm
gonna go back up here and see what's
going on lots maybe this one is open
yeah Tobin it's the manager's place
that's one
and I can't well I got a flashlight now
okay so it's not actually why it's f
wheelchair impressing what does that do
I gotta
private perfect nothing in here
well grace can expect to see us how
sound uh hello yeah I don't know
anything about stock I talk to parents
if their manager than me I find I'm so
wants to get out of here running Wow
very rude hello hey me again thanks for
not telling dad I'm writing I was just
changed I found this plant I'm gonna bed
took it to Terrence and he would not
client no wait there's a page to the
losses miners this white disappeared
Jane hey can Alice dig all through our
stuff
tonight go through this one that will
knock to him yeah that fake door yeah it
was just a current yeah
it's a office oh it's like a cave what
the huh
it's a puzzle yeah this is taking a
nine-game well this is taro says class
we're 9k got some bears piss bad
what smoking room smoked all not use
found out of all those plants can't defy
it five blood and sink a charge or 1/5
or have an affair and a dick ok ok
anything else here what Oh beautiful
bike and a happy about what yes I can't
actually my hot box ok oh what's wrong
is that five I'm not ki
okay
[Music]
189 is it with me okay let's go check
that out Hey well it's over thing ah
grace I'm stalking for week she's not
equipped to handle that said I think it
makes a great letter up Jake crash
company that corrected that she's my
she's I should've wrote that company
it's my opinion issue around did just
like ante room eight you're not are you
doing now later I can't like the other
thing okay so I could go to the bar now
this way that's really bad actually hit
again I check out though
okay so beautiful so you got that okay
what I have that habit for you know she
is haebang favorite drink honey now if
grace sounds like Connor well the good
news does that mean she's now a drink
with me when I hear that look crying we
can go up to my room
here's like hey I'm in room one that's
right above us you know minute before
right
no of course so I never sleep in there a
little while man that's what he done
don't mention me he's a hey that people
should behave
they said one five or I having an affair
dayson oh I eat Matt yeah right above us
he says but we're not Bob us that's Cal
let's go Elmont hello lady it's time
that way you sit together huh man I was
just leaving drinking sit well tell me
more I know that again
what is that I think I'll warmer so what
is that
how's that shadow return oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh no we're in the what is
that
hello sir what
what the heck Joe what have you done
since then why don't you dinner
I got you stupid a rope and I'll be long
now
y'all wait is down yeah well that's the
thing okay can I give this thing to that
guy that's this guy's thing oh there's
another chance
Hey
what the heck how's that sir huh I'm not
gay nothing's happening - oh no oh Sam
how many are there
yeah here we go
what the heck out of that that says I'm
topless for you ah this is the end of
that demo very nice thank you very much
now if I was gay behalf of the fall game
which evolution late yeah they did
and I'm gonna top jam Aska interesting
interesting and I don't like the models
of now and always thankful wasn't you
that gap